[Music]
welcome to the reason Roundtable your
top of the week libertarian podcast
brought to you by the magazine of free
minds and free markets I'm Matt Welch
joined by Nick Gillespie Peter suderman
and Catherine mangyu Ward hi gang howdy
hey Matt
happy Monday we are going to uh Endeavor
to try and figure out just what the hell
happened last week on Capitol Hill but
first a reminder that this episode is
brought to you by betterhelp friends do
you ever feel awesome
like those kids jumping off the rock and
a Mountain Dew commercial or that time
and Almost Famous when they all start
singing tiny dancer in the bus
well what's keeping you from being there
now how do you get to your good place
for millions of people therapy can help
remove obstacles and build new Pathways
toward getting to your very best self
that's where better help the world's
largest therapy service comes in
betterhelp has matched three million
people with professionally licensed and
vetted therapists it's an affordable
service 100 percent online and super
flexible if you don't like your first
match swap them out for another until
you find the right fit listeners who act
right now can get 10 off their first
month just go to betterhelp.com
Roundtable fill out a brief
questionnaire find a quicker path to
your better self that's better h-e-l-p
like pizzazz
go there today you'll be glad you did
all right so about last week today
Monday is the first real work day for
the 118th Congress which as of recording
time is voting on its own rules after a
series of both remarkable and but now
scenes last week when it took the
incoming House of Representatives and
it's very slim GOP minority 15 votes to
bestow the speakership onto the
so-called Bakersfield Comet Kevin
McCarthy a rebel block of 20 Republicans
centered in the House Freedom caucus
refused to support McCarthy vote after
vote until getting a bunch of promises
the ability to bring amendments to the
house floor which we haven't seen for
more than a half decade uh key committee
assignments for several of the rebels of
course a new church Commission in the
words of Thomas Massey to investigate
the Deep State and at least an oral
commitment to tether forthcoming
increases in the nation's debt ceiling
to Future spending cuts depending on who
you talk to the process was
entertainingly chaotic depressingly
nihilistic an advertisement for C-SPAN
and or a demonstration both for and
against the continued relevance
of Donald's day drum Donald J Trump
should not put initials in prepared
texts let alone read it uh Catherine
what did you learn from last week what
was your overall impression so I
actually will give kind of like a my
personal take which is that I went into
the week as
um maybe a little too in favor of status
quo you know let's just do things the
way we always do them I was kind of like
who are these what what are these
Shenanigans it's going to be McCarthy
let's just have it be McCarthy and move
on
and my colleagues here at reason
convinced me both with their genuine
personal Delight over said Shenanigans
and also uh with their excellent writing
on some of the substance of the demands
of these folks that there was more to it
and that actually maybe
um
you know they're at least some of the
demanded concessions I think will be
good things
um I think it's you know there there
really were echoes in there at least of
a kind of Republican party concerned
with fiscal discipline
in the end is it Shenanigans all the way
down I think so right I mean they are
not in fact going to have more time to
read the bills in the end they are not
in fact going to lash themselves to the
Mast of fiscal discipline in any
meaningful way
and they are in fact going to have some
kind of wacky people on committees who
previously would not have been on
committees um so I think that's probably
a real downside but um not to mention
there was a bunch of showy you know we
have to bring a vote to the floor about
medical care for a you know failed
abortion babies and all kinds of stuff
like that which I do not think will be
productive nor actually change
legislation in the end but
of I what I have long said is I want
voices on the hill who argue for fiscal
discipline even unto the point of
obstructionism I have expressed
Nostalgia about the old days of the Tom
coburns and such and um maybe I should
be careful what I wish for but I I think
I think I have come around on The View
that there may have been more good than
harm done in the last week
in the end a fun fact about Tom Coburn
is that when Republicans were uh under
the Trump administration were
negotiating I think it was a 10-year
budget you know uh blueprint
um he had uh said that he was not going
to prove anything if it raised the
long-term deficit by even one penny
um and now Tom Coburn is no longer in
the United States Senate uh Peter
um speaking of promises uh first what's
your overall impression of what happened
and second uh perhaps most pressingly
um when are we going to start finding
out whether or not these promises amount
to a hill of beans okay so my overall
impression is that we learned that um
Kevin McCarthy is going to be a very
weak speaker uh notably he never even
got a full majority he won the
speakership with 216 votes not with 218
because a group of people agreed to vote
present and that is going to mean that
he is not going to exert a whole lot of
control over this chamber um I think we
learned that Kevin McCarthy has an
endless appetite for embarrassment and
humiliation it's obviously some sort of
personal Kink not that there's anything
wrong with that we learned that
Democratic processes uh are or at least
can be quite chaotic and we also learned
um to Catherine's point that chaos can
produce some at least potentially
substantive gains so last week I said
that just because many of the
anti-mccarthy types are kind of clowns
does not necessarily mean that all of
their demands are pure goofy balls and I
think this week has borne that out I
would Point very specifically to the
process demands with regards to the
budget McCarthy has at least
theoretically agreed to return to
regular order and what that means is
that he has agreed to bring all of the
Appropriations bills uh the the spending
bills that make up the kind of uh the
sort of normal budget process
individually rather than all of them
rolled up as a single end-of-year
Omnibus Mega Bill and they've also as
part of that agreed to a process whereby
if they can't manage to pass all the all
of the the bills that would normally go
into an Omnibus if they can't manage to
pass those Appropriations bills they're
just going to do a continuing resolution
which means they continue on with the
same funding level now that that
agreement has already been portrayed as
oh that's tantamounts to budget cuts and
it's gonna be right it's gonna they're
gonna be cutting funding because if you
keep everything at the same funding
level then that that's cutting spending
in in Washington but that's that's not a
bad outcome necessarily now I don't
think we will get to see whether or not
uh they actually deliver on that promise
for many months possibly not until
basically until the end of the year
um uh probably you know towards
September or so which is when the
current uh funding bill runs out however
if we return to something like regular
order and if the alternative to regular
order is not you know a a giant Omnibus
but instead just keep things at the same
level of funding that we already have uh
whereby they are already operating
that's not a terrible outcome from all
of this
uh nick uh what was your overall
impression and do you have the sense
that uh we're going to see some of the
return to the politics and policy of the
2010 to 2013 era of sequestration cuts
and showdowns over the debt ceiling
increase yeah I don't know about the
latter but unlike my esteemed colleagues
I was absolutely enjoying the uh
spectacle of Kevin McCarthy the uh
Bakersfield Comet just uh you know he
was he was like kahotech Matt uh he was
supposed to be blazing across the sky
and said you could barely see them uh
he's you know as I've discussed before
and I really uh refer people to my
interview with Robert Draper author of
weapons of mass delusion for a longer
discussion of McCarthy's failings but
he's the worst kind of careerist
um and he is kind of a an apt dead end
for kind of the modern Republican
speaker he's going to be a weak speaker
but ultimately it's not simply because
he is a craven unprincipled person who
was anti-trump and pro-trump and this
and that
um you know who's got it in his
comeuppance but Matt I think that what
we witness over the past week was
actually something a fulfillment of one
of the main points of our book The
Declaration of Independence
which is that the parties are you know
have had a long drift over at least the
past 20 years into a functional
stalemate where neither of them can
maintain a strong majority because they
don't actually stand for anything they
represent coalitions that have you know
that were formed maybe in the 70s or 80s
but certainly no longer exists and as a
result cannot muscle through any kind of
significant long-term majority and we
should take Delight in the fact that it
was so you know first that the
Republicans couldn't get the majority
they should have and was predicted by
historical uh reality uh and second that
McCarthy himself struggled to do this
the Republican party is going to need to
reform itself and either recommit to a
pilot and actual politics and at least a
rhetoric of limited government if they
want to persist and and kind of increase
their majority
or the Democrats need to do something
because they are also have not been able
to maintain majorities for long periods
of time I think we should welcome this
as Libertarians and push on the things
that the you know the Renegades in the
Republican Party held out for which are
the kinds of formal
process-based reforms that would make
Congress actually more serious about
legislation and then we can work on the
actual content of that legislation The
Cutting spending is good although you
know it's unlikely and one of the things
that I disliked about the the
conversation about all of this along
with the Omnibus spending bill is again
that we're talking about discretionary
spending and you know which is a quarter
of the budget at this point I hasten to
add thanks to the corrective real-time
uh fact checking of nicholaspi that I I
dead named Tom Coburn
um
the person who I was referring to is Bob
Corker
not Tom Cobra Bob Corker uh from
Tennessee not Tom Coburn from wherever
Tom Coburn so oh thank you very much uh
you know I knew I was gonna get it wrong
so I might as well just not uh say it
can I also just say the one thing Thomas
Massey I feel has been wobbly from a
true limited government perspective uh
over the past few years
um I love the idea of of a new church
style commission but it will be ruined
if it if it is done in a starkly
partisan way which almost seems certain
I mean what was interesting ultimately
about the church commission and the
Rockefeller uh commission as well in the
mid 70s is that they represented a
majority in a kind of consensus of the
governing class as well as the people
that we really needed to look into
things like the NSA the CIA and the FBI
and and you know secret government
shenanigans
yeah as part of that if you go back and
look even at the senate or select
committee to investigate Watergate and
just read through the comments of the
Republicans at the time
um looking into this and promising to be
serious by looking into this and
contrast that to any of the kind of
ongoing partisan clown show that we have
right now it's a different world
definitely a different world there was a
uh in that uh struggling a mid 70s time
there was an attempt by a bipartisan
attempt at some amount of seriousness
whatever happened afterwards is a
different thing altogether but speaking
of Massey Catherine
um you know there was a lot of
discussion of Justin Amash was up on the
hill making a very uh fruitless attempt
to throw his hat in the ring and he was
sitting next to Thomas Massey his old
friend uh in uh Congress and Massey
voted for McCarthy every single time
just without any kind of question and
then afterwards in interviews he said
hey look we went after we being him into
mosh and freedom caucus we went after uh
John Boehner we went after Paul Ryan we
did all this kind of stuff and we didn't
get anywhere we just lost we didn't get
anything out of it this time because of
Chip Roy and because of uh I don't think
a lot of people credited Matt Gates
except with his hair but um
incredible forehead it was trending on
Twitter actually over the week but uh
Matt Rosendale who uh gave some actually
really excellent speeches from Montana
as part of this process and uh and other
people in the negotiations they actually
got somewhere so uh is uh is Massey
coming off smelling more like a rose too
there Catherine uh uh I don't know I
mean I guess you could make a kind of
like Massey and Amash walked so that
Peppa could run situation here I I don't
know like you know the part of the part
of this whole week of shenanigans that
was odd to me was that there was never
an alternative candidate
um and I think that that's you know that
wasn't their goal right their goal was
to was to force these concessions but
like there was no one in that cluster or
even willing to be associated with that
cluster respectable enough to put
seriously forward as a speaker candidate
and I I guess Amash would have said that
he was he was putting himself forward
um and I would love me in a mosh
speakership but it was not in the cards
you know if it's really three-fifths
vote to raise taxes if it's really 72
hours for bills if it's really cut go or
whatever we're calling it then yeah they
they did what many many of their
predecessors failed to do I'm skeptical
it's gonna stick
Peter um the proximate cause for in many
circles mainstream media circles
especially uh panic and other circles
um uh more fiscally conservative circles
uh you know some sense of of uh uh you
know long buried optimism uh is the debt
ceiling
um uh discussions coming forward right
now I think the projection is the debt
the limit on uh borrowing has to be
raised in July it's always kind of
slippery the way that they describe this
and what happens and in that process
given the way that the debt ceiling has
been more or less taken off the table
since 2014 by Republicans
um what do you foresee is as their
political ability to make the debt
ceiling uh any kind of Leverage point in
negotiations
within Congress and among the public at
large the real answer there is that no
one knows how that negotiation is gonna
go and there is a a real chance that it
is quite chaotic and that there is
significant Market turmoil as a response
to that and that there are Economic
Consequences
um but I don't think that's at all
guaranteed so let's let's just start
with I am perhaps a little bit of an
outlier on this podcast at least I know
Nick and I have sometimes disagreed
about the debt ceiling I understand why
Libertarians are like we shouldn't raise
the debt ceiling it sounds like the sort
of thing that you shouldn't raise you
don't want more debt right like that's I
totally get where Libertarians are
coming from but the thing is about the
debt ceiling is that spending has
already been authorized it is like it's
like buying you know a fancy dinner on
your credit card and then deciding that
what you need to do in order to cut
spending is to not pay your credit card
bill yes I know we're not supposed to
compare the Congressional budget to
household budgets but that's basically
the idea here is don't pay for for
spending that you have already
authorized it is uh and that's that I
think is is not necessarily the best
leverage point I would also point out
as you have just did Matt that under
Trump Republicans did not make the debt
limit an issue at all which at minimum
tells you that there is an awful lot of
hypocrisy here that they only care about
the debt limit when it when there is a
democrat in the white in the white house
uh who they can who they feel like they
can extract concessions from and make
look bad and because Democrats feel that
Republicans aren't negotiating in good
faith on the debt limit they feel like
um like Obama really got rolled in the
debt limit negotiations under during the
Obama presidency I think Democrats are
going to be fairly low to uh to give any
concessions here or not want to not
going to want to do that and so when you
have a party that is the Republican
party is very fractious and not together
and it's just going to be hard to Corral
you have a weak speaker as we've talked
about and you have Democrats not really
willing to give an inch on this as far
as I can tell I think you may may end up
in a situation that is somewhat
unprecedented where that we actually do
sort of go beyond the debt limit we
there there is something like a
technical default or or something in in
that zone it's you know sort of again
we've never done this before so it's a
little bit hard to describe exactly
what's going to happen and at minimum
there's going to be a market reaction
when that happens and it may take it may
take some
Economic Consequences I I guess is the
only way I can say this for uh to to get
through this at the same time uh I I am
happy to see and you know I'm happy to
see a Republican party that has returned
even to perhaps cynical and perhaps not
entirely in good faith
um rhetorical uh pushes for fiscal
responsibility obviously it would be
better if they were smart about this
stuff and if they had done you know
taken the chance to do to cut spending
and do things uh like this under Trump
they didn't
um at the same time it's always at least
welcome to have one party that is
talking about this sort of thing rather
than
um you know rather than both parties
that are just like well let's just keep
running up the tap
nick uh do you want to tell Peter why he
should uh stop worrying and learn to
love the uh debt uh limit yeah I I mean
I think both uh he and Catherine are
correct that it's uh you know it's hard
to see how this plays out in a way that
actually reduces spending but
um I think that's what we gotta we gotta
go for
um because you know federal spending you
know again most of it's on autopilot uh
but it has to be rained in uh the
problem is that the Republican party is
full of [ __ ] on this and they really
need to make a commitment to reducing
spending
um and actually make a credible
commitment to that and they also have to
find Democrats who are at least you know
somehow you know uh do some kind of
voodoo and bring back Blue Dog Democrats
or something but otherwise this is just
one more sign that the Republican party
is kind of out to lunch and is virtue
signaling uh you know when it comes to
the federal budget and they'll be
ignored there'll be a messy
semi-showdown which won't actually be it
and the result will be a big kickoff
into things the Republicans tend to lose
budget showdowns what was effective uh
with the in the Obama years was the fact
that Obama got that one or two year
massive increase in spending and then
things were held kind of steady until
Trump came into office then Cove had you
know let loose the barn doors on
everything but you know we need this we
need something we need to start talking
about why we are spending too much and
why that needs to change you know sooner
rather than later there's also some
history here that I think is just
relevant real quick since Nick brought
up Robert Draper earlier Draper had a
piece in the New York Times over the
weekend drawing a a direct line from the
Gingrich revolution in the 1990s to the
Tea Party to the Auntie McCarthy
rebellion and he argued that in
basically every case the initial drive
for fiscal responsibility
um kind of resolved into a politics of
cultural grievance and nihilism about
governing and I think that maybe you
know I'm not sure I agree with exactly
every phrase in his piece it's not a
total endorsement of every single idea
but that's not entirely wrong and if you
look at the trajectory of the Tea Party
in particular there was a lot of
excitement among small government types
and what did the Tea Party end up
delivering uh in the end it ended up
kind of transforming into the Trump Maga
movement which wasn't really about small
government
that one of the I I don't disagree with
that but one of the things in the 90s is
that we actually got pretty good
governance
um out of the once the Republican
Revolution took hold after the 94
election you know there were five years
of major significant bipartisan uh laws
that were generally considered pretty
effective uh and government deficits
went down mostly because the economy
increased but there was also some tax
cuts so uh cultural grievance is
frustrating and annoying to me I suspect
it is to many Libertarians but it's also
you know it's it's not the only thing
that was going on in the Gingrich years
um Catherine before we uh semi leave uh
the topic
um I wanted to give you an opportunity
to sing the Praises of having multiple
C-SPAN camera angles during the
proceedings last week absolutely
delicious I mean it we're really seeing
what we're missing out on I understand
that there's a kind of
it's a real repeat play hostage
situation in the in the chambers there
where C-SPAN wants to be in and wants
access and uh you know the
members of Congress don't want C-SPAN to
film the fact that no one's in the
chamber ever among other things
um but
everywhere else in our lives we now have
you know the sports Ballers with the
microphones on chitter chattering and we
get to hear it and you know up close and
personal confessionals interspersed with
whatever story is being told we need
this in Congress it's it was great to
see just the general kind of
floor interplay
um and I think it's You Know It
ultimately gives people a better
understanding of what's going on I know
the American people are not just out
here watching C-SPAN you know Washington
DC is a weird place but
um you know there are these kind of
still pictures that emerged from that
experience that were very telling you
know the one that looks like um a like a
Caravaggio of um you know the the all
the arms outstretched and like the one
the scene where like people are grabbing
each other and covering each other's
mouths the phone that just shows DT
calling like they were just it was it
was well Roosevelt was going talk to the
hand like Roger Taylor green is showing
the Trump call and he's like nope
absolutely not and like it they truly do
look like these kind of um you know
these these paintings of like the Roman
the Roman senate and and that's what we
should see so I yes I think the real
heroes were the C-SPAN camera operators
and they should be allowed to practice
their art more fully in the chamber I
always think a lot when I go to another
city and I go to the gym and no one is
watching C-SPAN you need to be stopped
oh yes Nick I will point out that uh
over 10 years ago I believe we had a
recent video which uh was talking about
the need for cameras in the Supreme
Court and we started with the fact that
there you know there has been a camera
there has been live footage from Katie
Couric's rectum the least we should do
is be getting 360 coverage of Congress
the White House and the Supreme Court
look it up
no
look at the video it's a good video it's
okay yeah this is just a basic Monday
morning hygiene situation all right
we're gonna go a little bit early to our
listener email of the week because it's
kind of related
do that in a moment but first friends
you might think you've done everything
in your power to ensure your family in
the case of a medical emergency but what
many of us don't realize is that health
insurance won't always cover the full
cost of for example an emergency medical
flight
if you require Air transport even
comprehensive coverage can leave you
with high deductibles and co-pays that's
where air Med Care Network comes in when
you sign up to become a member of the
air Medcare Network should any such
emergency arise you will not see a bill
for air Medical Transport when flown by
a provider airmed care transports more
than 100 000 patients each and every
year it's about a dozen just in the
duration of this podcast it's peace of
mind for you and your whole family can
be yours beginning at the low low price
of just 85 a year listeners to the
Roundtable can get gift cards with their
new membership for up to fifty dollars
through either Visa or Amazon simply
visit
airmedcarnetwork.com
reason and use the offer code reason and
start protecting your family do it today
you'll be glad you did alright reminder
email your short queries to Roundtable
at reason.com this one comes from Mark
Brokaw
who writes in the last episode you all
discussed ongoing process for electing a
new speaker of the house you discussed
the demand request of the 19 or so
Republicans who don't back McCarthy that
he returned to more normal house
proceedings like the introduction of
amendments debate on the floor Etc one
of their demands the introduction of the
fair tax bill was unaddressed on the
last podcast what do the panel members
think of the fair tax both within the
speaker vote context but also more
broadly I'd be interested in a
Libertarian take on the fair attacks
assuming that abolishing taxation is
unlikely does the fair tax represent a
much better alternative to our current
system Catherine
admire fair tax people they
go out there who are just
just like
still out here trying to make fair tax a
thing and I I applaud the commitment to
what feels like a very very very
difficult reach
as a general matter I think it's a good
proposal right um the the appeal of a
fair tax is that it's basically a
consumption tax that that therefore
dramatically reduces the opportunity to
use the tax code to manipulate Behavior
which is one of my biggest pet peeves
and also really reduces the like
incredible inefficiencies in the tax
code you may recall Martha McCarthy got
in trouble for saying that the IRS was
gonna hire tens of thousands of agents
to march to our doors and you know steal
our money and that that was the first
order of business was to roll back that
additional IRS funding well to vote for
it without it they're not actually going
to do it because to think about thinking
about thinking about the Senate and Joe
Biden are not going to let that happen
right and and in fact this is the fate
of the fair tax always it's like it's
not going to happen it's not going to
happen like stop trying to make fetch
happen but
it's a great idea in a world in which
this could be a thing I would like it to
be a thing I guess in some fair tax
proposals there is a A prebate or um
basically what amounts to kind of a
little bit of like a backdoor Ubi in
ways that make me a smidge nervous
because again my desire is to have as
few levers as possible to pull for these
idiots who are in charge and that
strikes me as one to pull that could be
a problem but um in general
The Vibes are are Immaculate the
likelihood of a fair tax actually
occurring still strikes me as near zero
but like you do you babies Peter you're
you're a technocrat at heart do you love
this or do you hate this I mean there's
things to like about it it's politically
impossible but like let's table that for
just a second
politically impossible is is that is
worth talking about still
um consumption taxes are more efficient
right uh so um the the vat taxes the
value-added taxes that they have in
Europe are extremely efficient taxes and
by efficient I don't just mean
um I mean they don't produce deadweight
loss which is a sort of Economics term
for like sort of uh for an economic a a
larger burden on the on the economy
um there are things to like about that
uh one of the reasons that it is
politically impossible though is that if
you don't have that prebate if you don't
or or some sort of rebate on your on
your fair tax then what it amounts to is
a tax hike on lower income Americans
because very a very large percentage of
the country right now effectively does
not pay income tax at all and so if you
say we're not going to have an income
tax but we are going to have a you know
uh basically a sales tax
as our primary mode of Taxation then
that ends up taxing people who make less
money who sort of who more of their more
of their income goes to kind of daily
spending that would fall under the fair
tax and so that is both something for
Libertarians to think about in terms of
well is that actually Fair
um there are certain people you know
certainly some people would say it's not
but even if you think that's fair oh
because it's just we're taxing the value
of the thing that you purchase right
regardless of whether of of how much you
make even if you think that's fair it's
going to be a huge political lift to to
sort of get that into the public
Consciousness where when like when you
hear Democrats just Hammer home
um or people opposed to the fair tax
just Hammer home the idea that this
means a tax hike on low-income earners
paint you as a skeptic of the fair tax
is that wrong uh yeah I think it is I I
agree that it's uh politically somewhere
between unlikely and impossible but uh
you know taxes should be visible Fair
easy to enforce and non-distorting and
the fair tax comes close you know as
Closer Closer on all of those as uh as
the current income tax so that's all
good
um the one thing from a Libertarian
perspective and I think both uh Peter
and Catherine kind of uh were getting to
this it's not going to minimize the
state in a particular way you might get
rid of whatever the IRS is now but then
you are going to have according to the
to the big plan you're you know which
would basically tax every uh uh exchange
uh you know uh every transaction at
about 23 of the the value of whatever
you're buying or selling
um you're you're going to have a prebate
you're going to need an age tell you
that kind of figures that out and then
sends that out you're going to have to
have something at the end of the year
where you tally up to make sure that the
prebates went to the right people and
not the wrong people or claw back
whatever was too much or kick in more so
it gets complicated pretty quickly but I
you know I I wish we had more discussion
of the fair tax even if it didn't lead
to a consumption tax and more that it
would get us thinking more about
Taxation and the way that the government
is distorting economic activity all the
time part of the problem with it too is
it's often talked about as a kind of
republican-ish kind of thing Gary
Johnson the former Republican governor
of New Mexico uh who ran as the LPS
candidate twice and did spectacularly
well by LP standards was a big proponent
of the fair attacks
um you know but the fact of the matter
is is Republican presidents whenever
there's a recession the first thing they
do is go out shopping publicly and say
hey go buy socks go buy [ __ ] which you
know the consumption tax would diminish
that
um like a soft pair of socks though to
make you feel comfortable yeah and Happy
on a Monday morning that would be your
economy's fading you know
um in this economy
my minimal contribution to discussion
would be Catherine mentioned Ubi
Universal basic income which in
um the best versions of it were have
been discussed as a replacement of
existing social safety nets but in a
practical application that never happens
this is my
um practical objection or the first
practical objection to a fair attacks is
that
um I'm all ears if you're getting rid of
the income tax and the IRS sounds good
even though Nick is absolutely right you
have to still create some new other
intrusive bureaucracy
um but the way that things work like
that in the real world is that it just
becomes a new thing to tack on it's not
as if the vat having countries of
Continental Europe are low tax low
intrusion entities
um they're not they find lots of ways to
tax the hell out of you in lots of
different places so
I have some worries about that um all
right let's um can I actually just say
one more little thing which is that um I
think there's a new you know the fair
tax proposal has been around forever
like I think it's older than I am and
the um a new Twist on it is the impact
that it would have on crypto
um because I do think there would be
kind of both a desire to like like
people are going to want to do
transactions off the books if that's
where a taxation lives right
um so first of all like what does that
do to cash probably kill it forever
um and second either it's the thing that
makes
you know people really adopt crypto in
order to evade taxation or it's the
thing that drives Regulators to finally
definitively Crush alternate modes of
exchange because that is the source of
government revenue so I think there are
some like secondary consequences that
are worth thinking about as well
depending on how much you care about
whether crypto survives
excellent points all right let's uh move
to a subject that many Republicans were
also speechifying about last week
whether they were Pro McCarthy or
anti-mccarthy uh crisis at the border
President Joseph Robinette Biden the
second this weekend made his first
presidential visit to the international
Frontier with Mexico announcing a new
policy to Triple the annual cap on
Refugee resettlement from Latin American
and the Caribbean to 20 000 and to
increase to 360
000 the annual non-refugee intake
combined from the basket case countries
of Venezuela Nicaragua hating Cuba while
at the same time increasing expulsions
of illegal border crossers and making
those people ineligible for re-entry for
five years
from the Associated Press a write-up of
this morning quote Biden's nearly
four-hour visit to El Paso was highly
controlled he encountered no migrants
except when his motorcade drove
alongside the border and about a dozen
were visible on the ciudad Juarez side
his visit did not include time at the
border patrol station where migrants who
cross illegally are arrested and held
before their release he delivered no
public remarks end quote Catherine um we
will talk about in a moment the
substance of these policy changes but
can you kind of eyeball the political
Optics of this first both the role that
the subject played in Capitol Hill last
week just fentanyl border like in every
other sentence uh and also uh Biden's
like weird defensiveness kind of uh
about it in terms of his public persona
I think Biden has every reason to be
defensive he has absolutely betrayed the
spirit of
the immigration policy that he ran on he
is absolutely done what
um from the mouth of Donald Trump would
have elicited howls of Rage from those
who um those who want to see more open
integration and of course I include
myself in that I think the visit to the
Border thing is weird like we really
really overvalue that I don't understand
why we want this like symbolic State
visit to the Border
um that doesn't strike me as a useful
activity honestly
um but
I would like to I I would like to see
Biden held accountable for the fact that
he is he is just saying out loud don't
come here get in line somewhere else I
don't care how bad your home country is
don't come here that is not what I hoped
for
from a Biden Administration on
immigration and um well I'm happy to see
some of those legal thresholds lifted
slightly it's not enough
Peter um despite Catherine's skepticism
when we have record numbers of people
coming through the border and the uh
border communities impacted and people
like throwing people on buses and
sending them to New York including Jared
Polis by the way yeah uh Governor of
Colorado it's like bussing migrants to
New York maybe the legal psychedelics
are taking effect
uh maybe it's okay for a president to go
uh and look at a policy that the
president is in fact in charge of and is
suing states to stop trying to be so
much in charge of well to some extent
the president is in charge here
obviously Biden is uh you know has some
um some authority to make decisions
about border enforcement at the same
time
the the root problem here is Congress
and it is that we do not have any sort
of coherent uh legislation when it comes
to immigration and that's because there
is no agreement in Congress about how
immigration should be handled
Republicans basically don't want to see
a lot of immigrants certainly they do
not want to see a lot of low-skilled
immigrants right they want to the extent
that Republicans are okay with
immigration they don't like the
competition yes
um and it's crazy you know they're
complaining about uh about the The Surge
of the border and about you know all the
destructive effects and like and and one
of their complaints for years has been
oh these people take away our jobs and
yet we have really quite low
unemployment right now this is this is
not an environment in which it's obvious
that immigrants are coming in and taking
people's jobs and just taking away
opportunities from native born Americans
um and there's there's not a lot of good
evidence that that happens anyway
um and so this is to to me you know
Biden's move is not entirely theater
obviously there's some substance here
but it is it is heavily political
theater and it is a result of the fact
that Congress cannot get its act
together that Democrats when they have
the power uh do not pass immigration
reforms in part because they are scared
to do so and that Republicans the
Republicans are have become increasingly
anti-immigrant as a party over the past
15 years or so and this it's and so in
some ways you know so I think that the
most of the blame lays on Congress but I
will say there is also the American
people because they because the the
voting public does not want a whole lot
of additional immigration here
um there is there really is that's why
you see polis uh you know why you see
even Democrats sort of um putting up
this oh we're we're going to be you know
we're going to push back on immigration
um is because there is a significant
part of the uh American voting public
that just thinks that we shouldn't have
any more immigrants or we should only
have the right kind of immigrants you
know a small group of you know highly
skilled workers that sort of thing and
that is a real bind for Congress to be
in is that they don't want to you know
sort of they don't want to
go against what they feel is is the you
know the the public demand here for much
less immigration and so I think that
there needs to be some if like if you
want more immigration in this country
you need to both convince members of
Congress but also you need to convince
you need to convince the country that
immigrants are good for America they are
and I think that that campaign is not
being waged to a large extent
nick uh Peter's righteous Congress
bashing uh notwithstanding
um the president and the executive
branch have a lot of leeway leeway that
was expanded during the Trump
Administration through Supreme Court
decisions through Obama by his actions
or attempted actions right um uh
although the the legal expansion I think
uh was uh or leeway was uh was uh Trump
at the Supreme Court but uh regardless
what are some practical Solutions well
first what do you think about what Biden
proposed as his kind of a new approach
um uh just now but what are some
practical things the president could do
if he wanted to go if we wanted to go
more in a Nick Gillespie Direction on
immigration well one and I think this is
worth kind of talking about in
trumpeting is recognizing that three of
the big sender countries who are
targeted here in Cuba Nicaragua and
Venezuela are either still actively
communist countries or were in recent
memory or are run by former communist
leaders uh when they were Communists um
that's something worth talking about
people are fleeing shitty economies
authoritarianism uh and you know places
that create not just political
repression but economic repression the
reason why they're coming to the U.S
more and more is because the U.S economy
as kind of sketchy as it is right now is
actually doing pretty well particularly
relative to other places as Peter noted
this you know is a time of record or
near record unemployment we need more
workers everywhere you go people are
talking about Labor shortages nobody's
talking about oh you know what like I I
I you know you know we we have too many
workers we don't need as many workers we
actually need more and more workers I
think uh some of the things that um
Biden did including uh raising certain
kinds of Asylum caps and things like
that that's good but what he failed to
do and this goes to Catherine's point
you know you don't go to the Border if
you're just going to ride around and you
know a big car with blackened windows
and nobody even knows you're there I
mean Biden may have thought that he was
you know he was he was going to Camp
David or something how would he know the
difference
um he should have been making a
statement at the border that I you know
he's done this and of the past with
varying degrees of rhetorical Excellence
talking about America as a nation of
immigrants talking about his own family
history and kind of reframing this of we
need immigrants we need new people new
workers new ways of thinking about
things to enrich and enliven our country
up through sometime in the 90s we still
called ourselves a nation of immigrants
there was a broad uh you know cultural
political commercial emphasis on the
benefits of immigration uh from you know
after World War II at least through
sometime in the 90s when it was really
Democrats who were leading the charge
against illegal immigrations over on
running California and that sort of
[ __ ]
um what what we need is a president to
start with who actually makes a real
case for the benefits of immigration
explains how legalizing more immigration
will reduce illegal immigrations and all
the worries and fears and problems that
that causes and then tuck it into a
national you know kind of Epic about you
know who we are and where we come from
and where we're headed I you know this
it starts rhetorically
um because the immigrants are going to
come whether it's legal or not uh but
once we get more comfortable with that
we can I think start to actually affect
the cultural and especially the
political changes that are needed
speaking of national epics uh George
Santos
[Laughter]
he's our Don Quixote
absolutely the newest craziest member of
Congress uh
potentially immigrant Roots by the way
that keep changing and getting knocked
out his immigration story is true ish
ish he's brazilian-ish she who knows
he's straight he's gay he's yeah I want
to do a lightning round in honor of him
uh now just wonderfully sad and lonely
he was last week sitting uh there's a
Jim Newell from Slade had a phrase a
radius of emptiness around him
um he has lied if you haven't followed
the story he's lied about just about
everything in his resume uh his
grandparents fleeing the Nazis is mom
dying on 9 11 his employees getting
gunned down at the Pulse Nightclub his
jobs his academic career his real estate
holdings lies all of it just lies so for
a lightning round because we are getting
on in years here on this podcast about
we go around the table
and each of us bring up uh uh other
great political resume patterns
throughout American history and what
ended up happening to them Peter why
don't you start
I just want to say that I think the
George Santos story is is a great
American story right it's about
self-invention yeah it's about how it's
about you can be whoever you want to be
in America
you can you can be Jewish
uh no uh so uh so uh in my pick for um
resume patter slash um biography
fabricator is our current President Joe
Biden who um acclaimed among other
things there's a great list put together
uh by Tom Elliott a couple of weeks ago
he has claimed that he was arrested
while trying to meet Nelson Mandela
he claimed that his son Beau was killed
in Iraq but Beau Biden died after uh
from brain cancer
um he claimed that he spent part of a
summer working as a tractor-trailer
driver uh he claimed that he graduated
at the top of his class in college in
fact he graduated near the by near the
bottom of his class
um he claimed his first job offer was
from an Idaho Timber Company
which apparently is not is not true
um and and this one is for Matt Welch he
also uh claimed that he hit a um a
368-foot home run uh in a congressional
baseball game
he did not
you know who did hit home runs in
Congressional baseball games Nick you
know the answer to this question I'm
assuming it's Dr Ron Paul Dr Ron Paul in
a Houston Astros rainbow jersey ladies
and gentlemen uh Nick I know this is
Biden's also your choice do you have
other uh embellishments you'd like to
add to uh his beautiful resume I mean I
you know Biden the greatest thing about
him was having to quit the 1988
presidential campaign for among other
things plagiarizing and English
politicians life story including having
coal miner parents or grandparents but
since Peter did that I just want to put
in a word for Elizabeth Warren uh who
lied at various points clearly either
openly lied or lied by a mission when
she was mistaken for the Cherokee
dissented uh lady that she claimed to be
at various points but
um the my favorite part of all of that
the whole story is that she added a
recipe to a cookbook of America America
Native American
recipes called Pow Wow ciao
but that is itself awful but what's even
better is the recipe she used were
plagiarized from a French cookbook yeah
according to Howard were they also just
like for Waldorf salad or something yeah
they were if they were French uh you
know I heard she uh included herb
tomatoes and crab with tomato mayonnaise
dressing yeah among other dishes you
know which obviously you know the uh the
Cherokee you know that's what they ate
on the Trail of Tears or something like
that sounds like a pretty good Bloody
Mary to me so Elizabeth Warren uh you
know needs to be remembered and I'm not
sure what happened to her you know I
know she was an academic uh but yeah I'm
not sure what's what she's up to these
days Catherine do you have a like
someone who maybe actually suffered
consequences from their stupid lying I
mean I don't know if he's suffered
consequences from his stupid lying they
had John Kerry let's talk about John
Kerry I he's like the most I think all
of us just want to kind of pretend that
never happened and by that I mean like
all of John Kerry's life and career
um you know to be swift voted
um is I supposed to have lies told about
you right and so there is there is this
idea that in the end all of these people
saying that Carrie exaggerated his
service record they were the ones proved
wrong I think that like technically true
like I think he did in fact receive
these medals all that kind of thing
um but if you follow the Swift boat
River to its source or whatever sorry
um what you find is the best mini
controversy I mean there's so many
carrying controversies but I just want
to focus on the question of whether he
did or did not throw away his combat
medals does anybody remember that yeah
yeah I think I know the answer he get he
gave this television interview in 1971
where he says he gave back I can't
remember six seven eight nine medals
and then when he was running for
president he was like uh
no I mean I wouldn't say the medals
exactly and then there was this whole
back and forth about whether he threw
away the ribbons but not the metals and
symbolically what that meant and it was
part of this moment where he was getting
this reputation as a flip-flopper and so
it was the same moment as the I voted
for it before I voted against it
it was just like he had this kind of
self-mythology and he said something
into a microphone in 1971 and never
thought for one moment that he would
have to like reconcile that you know
decades later and he did and he never
satisfactorily explained that like we do
not know what the status of John Kerry's
medals is to this day as far as I know
um the thing that always interests me
about these stories and I think Santos
and Biden are both part of this
phenomenon as well as Carrie which is
that I think these guys believe their
own lies
and I think everybody lies about
themselves maybe and politicians just
get caught I don't know I've I find it
to actually be like an interesting deep
question about like you know there was
also the Hillary Clinton helicopter
thing remember when she was like I was
under a sniper Fire coming off a
helicopter and then there was like video
of like a child holding flowers standing
on the tarmac greeting her like Hillary
Clinton thought that story was true when
she told it because we're not reliable
narrators and memory is flawed
I don't know what to do with that in
terms of how we hold our elected
officials accountable but
I think I think politicians have to
self-mythologize and then they do and
then it's a problem well I think there's
also this phenomenon where if you're a
politician telling your personal story
you you don't just tell it once you
don't just tell it twice you tell it
over and over again and part of what you
do if you are a good politician is you
shape and sharpen your stories as you
tell them over and over again a little
bit like comedians workshopping their
jokes right like it's the same basic
idea but oh I'm gonna get the call back
just right this time except they're not
comedians telling funny stories they're
politicians telling stories about who
they are that matter because they are
symbolic to the country and what they
represent and all of that and so if you
are a successful politician you are
almost certainly the sort of person who
is good at iterating your stories to
make them more effective over time and
probably your memories just sort of
reshape themselves in a way that is
convenient to telling those stories
I followed a link from Scott shackford's
piece on George Santos on our website
reason.com and uh it was just to uh
politifacts category of Joe Biden all
right let's click on that it is amazing
uh because every month he's out there
saying crazy crap that didn't happen
like Ah that's when I pinned my my uh my
my uncle with a purple heart as vice
president or something you know nope
didn't happen not remotely no record for
it doesn't make any sense with the
timeline and he's said it multiple times
I encourage people to go check it out
and to be freaked out that uh you know
the president of the United States is
saying
untrue things about his life and his
actions
um uh as presidents and as a politician
out there my example uh is a person I
don't even remember existing in the past
but I looked this up and it was fun uh
named Wes Cooley a republican from
Oregon a freshman Congressman 1994 so
he's part of the Gingrich wave uh and he
had said that uh you know he'd seen
combat as a member of the army special
forces in Korea uh the only problems
being that uh he had never uh deployed
uh anywhere for combat and he would
never serve in the Special Forces
just a little detail really there's some
details uh he also said that he was a
Phi Beta Kappa he wasn't uh he uh also
lied apparently about how long he'd been
married to his wife in order for her to
collect survivor benefits from a
previous husband he eventually was a
convicted of lying uh uh in an official
document about his military record which
is uh apparently a crime I thought it
was a free country but uh yeah it's a
crime uh and instead of uh being
censured in any formal way he just uh
didn't run for re-election and was
bounced out after a uh ignomonius is
that the word uh well a single term in
the mid 90s from Republican Shout Out
West Cooley he's also uh like uh Tom
Coburn a dead
um so we have a lot of liars among us
and it is creepy
um and they should be pointed at and
laughed at constantly having said that
there seems to be a very loose
correlation between and being a liar and
being successful Ronald Reagan also
misremembered many details from either
movie roles he had or kind of signal
core films that he uh that he filmed
during World War II with actual World
War II experiences among other things so
fabulism and being a good politician
yeah you know they're like they're in
separate uh separate categories is the
bridge there just like method acting
like these guys are just so method that
they lose touch with reality I don't
know I also think the Santos you know
the Santos story as much as it is uh a
joke or a story about politicians it's
also a cautionary tale about bad
journalism
um the fact even his opposition research
file didn't like check any of his facts
they just kind of listed it it's you
know this all should have come out I
mean if if the Press is actually a
countervailing force to politics boy we
we really took the easy Road out on this
one there was a local paper that uh
wrote about some of the stuff in
September but no one picked it up and
were cared
um I think it's also a cautionary tale
about two-party politics right like
people didn't vote for Joe Santos
because of his resume devoted for him
because they live in the suburbs of New
York and were pissed off about Democrats
uh this cycle and he was the guy with a
republican uh on his sweater all right
let's go to our end of uh podcast what
we all have been consuming Peter what
did you consume
I saw Raiders of the Lost Ark
in a movie I've heard I've heard of that
one yeah and so it was a Revival
screening at the local Alamo Drafthouse
and you know what it's a pretty good
movie guys yeah it's a pretty good movie
uh I have seen Raiders of the Lost Ark
dozens maybe hundreds of times before
but never in a theater and it just plays
different on the big screen it's more
engrossing and more obviously
crowd-pleasing in the same way that
seeing a band Live can show you how
their songs are designed to appeal to a
mass audience uh in the moment
um seeing a movie in the theater with a
crowd just lets you understand like wow
this movie Just is constantly like
giving the the audience like a a hug and
saying like love me right but like in in
a way that is like totally appealing
um you see I think on the big screen
more than ever how much this movie
relies on Harrison Ford's eyes very
specifically there are all these
close-ups where you see him moving his
eyes perfectly precisely and then you'll
see what he's seeing and Spielberg is
putting you in Harrison Ford's eyes and
letting you see uh letting letting you
see how he is sort of analyzing the
what's going on uh in the scene and
what's surrounding him
um and and often it's just the geography
of the set right and so Spielberg is
notably uh just the master of action
Cinema
um the the total Clarity of his
compositions uh of the geography of the
objects in the screens the way he just
sort of shows you here's a bunch of
stuff right set you know sort of set out
for us to to play with in an action
scene and then every one of these things
just sort of goes off in a mousetrap
manner right like it's just a succession
of chekhov's guns all of which have been
laid out at the beginning of the scene
and then all of which just sort of pop
pop pop pop pop throughout the rest of
the movie throughout that through at the
end it's it's just so great how many how
many perfect
um physical setups and payoffs there are
in that movie you also see how much of
it seems to draw from of all things
Looney Tunes there are so many good
little cartoon gags in this movie and
similarly uh you see I I think you're
reminded of how much early Spielberg was
really he had a kind of gleeful
um interest in grotesquery and there's
so much sort of like cartoon Gore and
violence in this movie that is it's not
like it's I mean it's it's much more
gory than you'd see in any PG or really
even PG-13 movie today at the same time
it's very much in that sort of cartoon
you know almost a Mad Magazine sort of
mold of like oh sure this is this is
horrific but it's also kind of wild and
kind of funny and you can see that that
sort of glint and Spielberg's eye is
he's like yeah that's how that guy's
face should melt off it's just wonderful
and it's also it's also kind of a great
uh subversion of the action adventure
hero in that um in in the you see how
much Indiana Jones is kind of a jerk who
doesn't play the part right he is he
cheats like he just can't read the that
famous scene uh where there's the the um
the guy with the sword who like either
sets up a big confrontation and Indie
just really tiredly pulls out his gun
and shoots him but also like when the
big hulking German guy fights him in
front of the plane the first thing Andy
does is kick him in the balls because
Indiana Jones is not like a nice guy who
plays by the rules he's the guy who
leaves he was a Nazi
you kick him in the ball you love him
for it he leaves Marion in the tent
constantly he's like she she's like
rescue me and he's like no I'm not gonna
do that that would foil my plan because
he's a jerk and then at the very end of
the movie does he does he himself take
out all the bad guys all the Nazis no he
just says close your eyes don't look
let's let God do the work and so that's
the other thing that I that I saw her
alerts that's the other thing that I
noticed in a way after having seen the
fablemans uh how much uh how much this
the the Nazi antagonists it's kind of
personal for Spielberg in a way that I
don't think I had realized when I was
eight or nine and first seeing this
movie is like no the end of the movie is
like these guys messed with the Jews and
the the god of the Hebrews is like I'm
gonna melt your face off not the not the
action adventure hero who was you know
set up as our our protagonist it's just
God it's the god of the Jews he comes in
he's like nope Nazis you get what's
coming to you and that's what happens
and it's it's wonderful it's just such a
great experience uh if you have an
opportunity to see it on a big screen
you should and yeah this is Spielberg
maybe his fourth best World War II movie
after Saving Private Ryan Schindler's
List and of course 1941 Matt's favorite
Spielberg
all pictures about Long Beach are uh are
number one on any list uh to Peter's
point about the big screen I saw that on
opening day in Irvine California as one
does uh when it came out you didn't have
to deal with homeless people Matt Welch
or lower middle class people yeah uh or
even pickup trucks parked out front of
the house we have standards around here
cookie cutter ticky tacky world or
Suburban Southern California uh go see
it on a big screen even him Peter
talking about it uh I have a perfect
flashback in my brain of the long
extended opening scene in the South
American jungle and it just envelops you
it's amazing you cannot get that
experience uh watching it even on your
home big screen TV it's a great movie
all right Catherine save us from all
this juvenile spielbergenia I enjoyed it
actually
um I read cat rosenfield's new book uh
she is of course a sometimes reason
contributor and Video Star her book
comes out tomorrow and uh she was kind
enough to send me an advanced copy it's
called you must remember this it's a
novel and
um I reviewed her previous novel
no one will miss her this book is
similar in many ways in that it's kind
of it's got a little bit of like a mix
of genres going on
um the advertising copy suggests that it
is a Knives Out style whodunit so I'm
just I guess all in on every Glass Onion
everywhere forever and ever amen
um but that's
um that's a little bit of what's going
on here it's
um it's really good again not
necessarily the genre I usually read but
um but I found it to be particularly
good in that the the main character the
protagonist is a 26 year old woman whose
voice
and combination of worldliness and
abysmal ignorance is exactly right for
what it is like to be a 26 year old like
no offense to the 26 year olds on reason
staff but she just she's really smart
she's really observant she understands a
lot about the world and also the older
people in the story
are like
I'm sorry you didn't understand these
five crucial things about the world and
she's like no absolutely not I did not
um in a way that just felt very real so
um I liked that a lot it had some Agatha
Christie energy it had some Knives Out
energy
um
the uh best bit and this is a slight
spoiler but very slight
um for those of us who are on the side
of the internet that briefly lost its
mind about the uh Negroni with champagne
or Prosecco on top
um the Negroni spagliato
um that like the whole world discovered
those and drank them in October
um this book ends with that drink but
must have been written before that
moment so cat Rosenfield manifested the
Negroni spagliato moment in our reality
and we should thank her for that
um speechless uh Nick what did you
consume I watched a new documentary film
called The Invisible Extinction which is
all about the human microbiome and how
inside our gut bacteria or our gut
bacteria is uh being uh diplined does
that even make sense no diminished
perfect replenished I like that and we
need to replenish it in various ways
it's like one of those words Edward
Norton uses in glass onions
bacteria yeah the invisible Extinction
though as a documentary that was I
should put out there was uh co-produce
executive produced by Jerry orstrom
reasons uh chairman of our Board of
Trustees but uh which is why I saw it
when it opened in New York it also has
some showings in LA but it's available
video on demand if you care about uh
kind of progress of science watch this
document documentary that the actual
subject matter is fascinating about how
the microbiome our gut you know our gut
bacteria forms who we are limits who we
are enables who we are it's all
genuinely fascinating on that but then
the larger frame is how does science get
done and how do we progress in science
uh so I highly recommend the invisible
Extinction uh like I said it's limited
showings in New York and LA but you can
watch it on Amazon Apple TV Vimeo on
demand Google Play pretty much any
streaming service uh you can you can
download it or uh you know for rent or
buy but highly highly recommend
invisible Extinction don't eat before
you say it
uh so I've been on a an ongoing series
with my soon-to-be eight-year-old
um looking at documentaries and other
films associated with ancient uh
civilizations uh so we've kind of
marched through recently uh from the
Egyptians to the Jews to the Greeks
um and we uh now uh went looking for uh
Romans right that's what you do after
the Greeks and so uh it's kind of
difficult to just do a you know hey
machine give me the good documentary
that's all right for kids uh about uh
ancient Rome and stumbled upon one that
um it's been very uh effective so far
I've seen two of four episodes It's a
Mary Beard's ultimate Rome uh Empire
without limit Mary beard is this very
funny kind of uh affable British
classicist she's associated with the
British Museum and she kind of tromps in
her uh high tops which the camera loves
a little bit too much uh through uh all
these different Roman ruins in different
cities including Leon France shout out
to Leon
um but uh spectacularly in places in
Algeria that I never heard of and uh and
just kind of describes the Roman Empire
she's British it was done in 2016. it's
BBC there's a little bit of extra
britishness about it and the founding of
London which is a Roman settlement which
I kind of didn't know
um and uh and she's dealing with themes
that uh certainly resonated in England
Paul English politics and at the time so
a lot of immigration assimilation
questions and and uh citizenship
questions and such uh but it's just
really good um if you watch it with your
seven-year-old or someone of similar age
um uh you know it's not made for kids
there might be some uncomfortable
questions like Daddy what's rape so
that's not always so great but
everything else about it uh was uh and
is just really good um hour-long
episodes perfect length for a kid's
attention span
and if anyone out there listening uh has
other recommendations that uh or would
be good for a uh a brainy little kid
who's interested in this stuff about any
other ancient civilization please feel
free to drop me an email or a comment or
whatever and not a comment I'm not gonna
read it uh an email uh so that's it uh
thank you very much for listening
um if you like our uh stuff at reason
Foundation consider giving us a tax
deductible donation reason.com donate
all of our podcasts live at reason.com
podcast Nick what can you tell us about
anything that's coming up in the
interview with Nick Gillespie world
slash speakeasies in New York City yeah
on Wednesday we will be releasing last
week's Speakeasy which was about harm
reduction as drug policy uh with Andrew
tatarsky and Maya solovitz uh that's on
Tappan in about a month uh double
checkout at reason.com events but we'll
be having another Speakeasy on Monday
February 6th with the aforementioned cat
Rosenfield ah talking about uh The Lure
of mystery thrillers and also the dread
threat of cancel culture and uh Speech
police
uh she wrote a recent uh very uh
excellent piece that was put up on
reason late in 2022 I'm not mistaken
um All About a topic that I've
conveniently forgotten but it has to do
with Kanye West
um but uh anyways uh thanks we'll catch
you next week uh I think on Tuesday
right Catherine you're the boss is
Martin Luther yep Tuesday so Tuesday it
is uh thank you goodbye
[Music]